chez les léveillé rodier comme chaque
matin depuis lundi la journée d'école
commence c'est la classe 9 heures
premier cours en ligne celui d'arthur
qui est en première année et les cours
démarrent ce lundi alors que la mère
supervise le court de son fils elle aide
sa fille de 5e année a terminé ses
travaux de français deezer c'est le
cours d'anglais de juliette qui est en
6e année
amélie est débordé ça fait quand même
beaucoup de gestion d'horaire en plus
faible que chez nous on essaie de faire
c'est de travailler depuis le début du
mois le ministre de l'éducation jean
françois roberge demande aux enseignants
du primaire d'entrer en contact avec les
élèves au moins trois fois par semaine
mais ici c'est beaucoup plus que ça au
total ces trois enfants ont plus d'une
trentaine de rencontres en ligne avec
leurs enseignants cette semaine ça reste
quand même qu'ils ont besoin que je sois
là pour les aider à passer au travers de
la matière on s'est vraiment fait donner
la job du professeur
pour finir l'année mais ce n'est pas
tout les parents qui sont débordées tous
les élèves qui sont inondés de travail
malgré les directives la situation varie
beaucoup d'une école à l'autre d'un
enseignant l'autre inde encore des
parrains qui sont en attente d'avoir des
nouvelles de leurs proches faudra des
preuves de deux heures de leur enfance
dans cet appartement à montréal samuel
qui est en 2e année aura deux cours en
ligne avec son professeur cette semaine
son petit frère yanis qui est en
maternelle et qui a des troubles du
langage n'a toujours rien reçu de son
enseignant leur mère est découragée où
on les a oubliés lui pisser c'est ses
amis de la classe et je trouve ça je
trouve ça dommage je trouve ça triste
parce que c'est un enfant a besoin
particulier triste aussi de constater
que d'autres petits québécois ont plus
de soutien de suivi de leurs professeurs
on est dans le même réseau s'est pas
privé public c'est pas y'a pas s'il ya
pas cette comparaison là on est dans le
même système
donc qu'est ce qui pourrait expliquer
cette inégalité ainsi on est supposé
être égaux si nos enfants sont supposés
être égaux pour celle qui représente les
érections d'école à montréal les parent
doit porter plainte
on voit qu'il ya des différentes
vitesses ça c'est sûr on est d'accord
qui sait pas ce qu'on veut si le prof en
donne trop parce qu'on sait que ça peut
arriver
s'il donne si le prof ne donne pas ce
travail
aussi il faut interpeller la direction
de l'école amélie elle espère que ses
enfants vont retourner à l'école en
septembre prochain mais elle a des
craintes et sonné pour continuer comme
ça à la rentrée oui je trouve un peu
décourageant ici jean philippe robillard
radio canada mon